- [Instructor] What we're
looking at is a graphic
that's put together by
"The New York Times,"
and it's a way of
thinking about how incomes
have grown since 1980.
So before we even look at the
various percentiles of income,
this black line is interesting to look at
because this is real per capita GDP,
and you can see relative to 1980,
real per capita GDP has grown,
it looks like, about 80%.
And that's interesting because, in theory,
if all of the growth of
productivity of a country
were evenly distributed, then
everyone would be growing
on that per capita GDP line.
But what's interesting about this graphic
is we clearly do not see that.
So, for example, folks with incomes
in the 90th to 99th percentiles,
their income actually is growing
inline with per capita GDP.
And, in the year that this was compiled,
that would be someone, after taxes,
making 120,000 to 425,000
per year after taxes,
so that's a good amount of money.
Someone making 425,000 after taxes
might be making roughly 700,000
or even $800,000 before taxes.
But we see a spread for people
making more or making less.
The folks in the top 1%,
their income has grown about twice as fast
as per capita GDP, and folks in the 0.01%,
so this one out of every 10,000 people,
their income looks like it has grown
roughly five times faster than GDP.
And, obviously, if some folks' incomes
are growing faster than per capita GDP,
other folks' incomes
have to be growing slower
than per capita GDP, and we can see that.
The middle 40%, their growth,
it looks like it's about 2/3
as fast as per capita GDP,
and the bottom 50%,
it looks like their growth is
about 1/3 of per capita GDP.
Now some folks might say,
"Hey, this is alarming.
"We see an increase in
inequality as our economy grows,"
while some might say,
"Hey, this is a side effect of capitalism.
"Everyone's income is
growing in real terms,
"but in a capitalist world
"some people might grow more than others."
But regardless of your point of view,
it's interesting to think about why
we see this spread happening.
And we're not going to be able
to dissect all of it right now,
but I'll talk about some
of the areas of interest
that might explain this phenomenon,
and it's not in any particular order,
but some folks would
point to globalization.
Why would globalization do this?
Well, in the globalized world,
capital can flow to wherever
they can get the cheapest labor.
And so, for example, if you're someone
in the top 1% or someone in the 0.01%,
and you own a company,
you could take your capital
to a lower cost place.
You don't have to make
wages in your country go up,
and so the demand for labor
is going to go offshore,
and so there will be less demand
for labor in your country,
so it wouldn't drive wages up.
Another possibility that folks
could talk about is technology.
Technology, oftentimes, has similar effect
as globalization.
Instead of taking labor
and taking it offshore
to find cheaper labor,
technology, oftentimes, can replace labor.
Or another way to think about it,
it can make folks more productive
so you don't need as much labor.
And so the folks who own the technology
or who are able to take advantage
of technological trends,
well, they might get a
disproportionate amount
of that GDP growth.
Related to both of these
is the idea of education.
Maybe in a globalized world
and a technology world,
the payback of education
matters even more,
and so if someone doesn't
get as much of an education,
they can't participate in the benefits
of technology as much,
or jobs that they're
qualified for go offshore,
so they can't demand as high wages.
Another potential lever to think about
is immigration policy, which,
from a wage point of view,
could have a similar effect as
technology or globalization.
If you have an increase in supply
of lower skilled labor,
economics will tell us
that the price for that
labor, which are wages,
would be suppressed.
Another major lever that
folks will definitely point to
is tax policy, or fiscal
policy in general.
For example, generally speaking,
the ordinary income tax rates,
the more money you make
become a higher and higher
percentage of your income,
but people in the very high brackets,
in that top 1%, or in that
top 1/100 of a percent,
many of their income
comes disproportionately
from capital gains, income
on asset price appreciation,
and that time of income, today,
is taxed at a significantly lower tax rate
than ordinary income.
And then last, but not least,
you have monetary policy.
And this is the actions
of the Federal Reserve
and interest rates, and many times,
especially when you go through crises,
the benefits of lower interest rates
might disproportionately
benefit those who own capital,
who are in the position to borrow
at those lower interest rates
and then invest it at
higher interest rates,
and that might speak to some
of these higher brackets.
So I'll leave you there.
The goal of this video isn't
to make a value judgment
over what's good, what's bad,
or what likely is the case,
but it's just to get us
thinking about the trends
that we are for sure seeing
and what might be the levers,
and this isn't an exhaustive list,
that might be causing them.